mathematically measure the perfect slice
with the protractor pizza cutter and
wear it proudly around your neck using
the pizza pouch because it's episode 57
of loose think before you drink by
resting your beverage on a brain
specimen coaster when stacked in the
proper order these ten slices give you a
full brain that will send your
cerebellum into celebration
keep that cranial stimulation going by
spreading on some caffeinated peanut
butter and then make your friends jelly
by showing off your brick box a monthly
subscription box that's a treasure trove
of LEGO sets minifigures and related
brick products in case bricks in a box
aren't enough the ever block is a
modular building block system that
allows you to build just about anything
they come in different sizes shapes and
colors and the website offers showcases
for furniture stage sets room dividers
and actual literal buildings if your
stress level is building relieve the
pressure with this ahh form a scented
donut stress ball squeeze the delectable
pastries that smell like the real thing
just donut put them in your mouth or
your woolly mammoth dog costume mammoth
mouth get it keep your hands abominably
warm while wearing these USB Yeti hand
warmers with low or high warped settings
to keep your paws toasty while you're
outside jotting down heavenly
observations into this stargazing
notebook if you're puzzled by light in
the sky allow the Rubik's Cube lamp to
puzzle the light in your home the
rechargeable light twists and turns just
like a real Rubik's Cube and connects to
a power source via USB see the sands of
time fall magnetically through the
magnetic sand timer an ordinary
hourglass filled with iron filings that
create a new unique sculpture every time
and if you enjoyed that pun give
yourself a high-five a wind-up high-five
for those who prefer their magnets in
the form of spinning orbs there's the
aptly named spinning magnetic
orbs the magnets are independent of the
shell so you can interact with them in a
gamble mounted 360 degrees spherical way
play cards the undead way by dealing a
deck of zombie playing cards which
includes spooky survival tips in case of
zombie attacks attach some sushi to your
sleepy face with stuffed sushi handmade
plush sushi pillows and if you sashimi
wearing these shades and need a bottle
opened I'll crack it open using the hook
titanium bottle opening sunglasses rich
you could store safely and majestically
on Perry the carved peacock eye glasses
holder now hold on to your x-ray
knee-high socks because this Jack Frost
mask by O'Neill FX Studios is incredible
there are actually a ton of amazing
masks on the website to make this the
best Halloween ever but wait there's a
Halloween episode of loot for you to
watch right now over on dong a brand new
channel for all the Vsauce shows filled
with things that you can do online now
guys so go check it out Michael Jake and
I all have videos waiting for you make
sure you subscribe to dong and as always
thanks for watching
you